the bad batch is a love letter to star
wars continuity and the more you know
about the series the more you'll get out
of it
after all the show is packed with small
details designed to get hardcore fans
and a tizzy
here are a few examples you might have
missed the bad batch pilot pays tribute
to its clone wars legacy right off the
bat
first the clone wars logo appears on
screen only to be burned away and
replaced by the bad batch insignia the
first episode of the bad batch then
launches into a saturday morning serial
inspired recap just like the ones that
kick off every episode of the clone wars
as on the clone wars the opening
voiceover is performed by actor tom kane
who also played yoda on the older series
however in late 2020 kane tragically
suffered a stroke inhibiting his ability
to speak which may unfortunately soon
lead to his retirement from voice acting
if that's the case the bad batch opening
isn't just a nice way to bridge the gap
between the two shows
it's also a wonderful tribute to one of
the star wars animated series signature
voices solidifying kane's legacy in a
galaxy far far away
officially the bad batch isn't actually
called the bad batch
in the republic and later imperial
records the group of misfit clones is
actually known as clone force 99
as clone wars viewers know that's a
number loaded with significance
i am merely stating a scientific
hypothesis based on factual data
in the season 3 clone wars episode clone
cadets which is chronologically speaking
the first time that we meet bad batch
member echo were introduced to a clone
known as 99
compared to the other clones he's a
little different something went wrong
during 99's creation and he was plagued
by a number of genetic defects that
rendered him unfit for duty
he basically became a glorified janitor
in camino home of the republic's cloning
facilities
99's hearts however worked just fine
despite staying away from the front
lines 99 considered all clones
particularly those still in training as
his brothers and ultimately gave up his
life to keep them safe
clone cadets is actually the first time
in star wars canon that we hear someone
use the phrase bad batch which is said
in reference to ekko and his original
team
it makes sense that the republic squad
made up of divergent clones would name
themselves after the most beloved of
their number
however the name clone force 99 also has
more sinister connotations
if you turn 99 upside down you get 66
the name of the top secret order that
resulted in the jedi's extinction at the
clone's hands
the bad match is about everyday soldiers
in the trenches not the high and mighty
battles bought by the jedi in the sith
but you'll still see a few
lightsabers in the latest star wars
cartoon the series pilot for example
gives us an up close and personal look
at how clone force 99 reacted to
palpatine's order 66
by detailing the execution of jedi
master depa billaba and the escape of
her padawan caleb dune
of course if you're all caught up in the
animated star wars shows you know caleb
by a different name
kanan jarrus which is the identity he
uses in star wars rebels where he leads
the titular group of freedom fighters
interestingly this is actually the
second time we've seen kanan's brush
with order 66.
the 2015 marvel comic mini-series kane
in the last padawan shows us a slightly
different version of these events
in the comic blabba tells kanyon that
she'll be right behind him as he flees
and the bad batch itself isn't seen
still it seems like the bad batch
creative team had the comic in mind
while designing the scene
the clones hunting caleb in the last
padawan had red markings that recall the
paint on the bad batch's armor
while one of the republic soldiers
hunting caleb says good soldiers follow
orders
a line repeated by crosshair in the bad
match pilot
once a bad batch returned to camino but
before crosshair betrays them and
they're forced to go on the run the
defective clones spend a little bit of
time unwinding in their quarters
there's no doubt that the clones have
made the room their own on textbunk for
example you can see schematics for some
kind of device etched on the wall
hunters is decorated with the bad
batch's skull symbol while printed out
targets featuring battle droids hanged
by crosshairs bunk showing off his
prowess as a marksman
the most curious piece of decorating
however is right by the front door
as the bad batch enters the room wrecker
assumes the job of updating the team's
successful mission count
which is scratched into the wall a quick
camera pan reveals that the bad batch
has already finished 55 missions
while recker says he's adding 11 more
what does that add up to
why 66 of course which as we already
know
is a very ominous number in star wars
canon
the star wars universe isn't hurting for
unbelievably cute creatures
that goes for the cartoons too the loath
cat an adorable little predator native
to the planet lothal was introduced in
star wars rebels and has been the
animated series go-to mascot ever since
while the bad batch doesn't visit lothal
in the plot it's not too surprising that
the loft cap makes an appearance anyway
omega finds a stuffed animal while
searching the bearings and it pops up
briefly earlier in the episode
the plushie belongs to wrecker showing
us that the big brook tests a softer
side
it's also pretty clearly a loft cat
albeit one decked out in the bad batch's
signature red and black
the bad batch aren't the only divergent
clones on kamino the bad batch pilot
also introduces us to omega a young girl
who is much more than she seems
my name's amiga for one she's the first
female clone we've seen in the star wars
canon
for another she's the protege of
camino's chief medical officer
a strange position for a clone there's
clearly something special about her and
while the bad batch hasn't clued us into
what it is just yet
chances are it's something big the bad
batch is the first time we meet omega
but if you're a long time star wars fan
she might look kind of familiar
squint and omega is almost a dead ringer
for sindal tawani one of the human leads
in ewok tv movies
the wavy blonde hair the stylish
headband the ampish grin
in terms of continuity there is no
obvious link between the two characters
but it's hard to imagine the bad batch
crew didn't have cindel in mind when
designing omega
in those made for tv ewok films syndal
is the youngest daughter of a family of
settlers who crash land on the forced
moon of endor thankfully the ewoks are
always there to lend a hand
from what we've seen so far omega is
very different from sindal but there
aren't many kids who get the spotlight
in star wars so it's not a stretch to
say that they're cut from the same cloth
at least character design wise check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about star
wars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one